I watched the movie last night and there
was a couple of scenes in the movie that
that were quite shocking to me there's
one that brought up a problem that I'd
even know that young people contended
with it has you guys taking too much
viagra your characters take viagra and I
always thought that okay that's that's
what young people are doing yeah
and that it make it creates this problem
that will not go away
and so in and you want to relieve
yourself and so the only way to do it is
both of your characters end up planking
on their toilets yeah well I think we
have photos of this while there and I
think we have both of you there yeah
there you go where's the shots from the
movie yeah those are dressing shots I
was just surprised I was I remembered I
saw that scene and I was like okay is
this is that the kids are up to now is
taking Viagra I think it's kind of like
a foolproof it's like a backup you know
because you can go out and you can drink
a lot and then you can forget hey I'm
also trying to do this thing but this
little pill says hey I'm gonna remind
you anyway
it's like a little alarm clock that you
set and then forget about it but now now
they say like if your erection lasts
longer than four hours call your doctor
but does your doctor tell you to then
put the erection in the toilet yeah let
it cool yeah I knew also this kid he was
in college II said oh the big thing in
college now is you we shoot sea house
into her eyeballs and I thought that was
crazy I thought that was like we know
from oh it's crazy ya know I thought the
Allison well okay
on this on this this is what the kids
are doing coach I'm just let either I
boner yeah
I don't know glasses go shoot I'm gonna
ask you guys directioner you had
personal experience with with Viagra
have you you know you guys are young
guys I wouldn't think that would be
something you'd have to you know I can't
confirm or deny that hey I I the friend
of a friend yeah my buddy use yeah
notorious for just randomly act you know
gas stations they have these like like
horny goat weed or erotic Blackmagic 7o
and so my buddy
yeah but he would always like buy these
things to try them out and nine times
out of ten he would end up throwing up
and going colorblind but that was his
thing he would just take these pills to
just see what would happen right yeah
but most the time he'd go colorblind
okay that is nobody is yeah I know what
color is and it suit right now have a
good time yeah no I had a friend of a
friend try it like a half of a half of a
half of a Viagra and my friend told me
it turned him into like a horse and then
everyone just gets tired
[Applause]
and then you just don't know what to do
there's just it's like you will sign in
the ads side effects include turn two
into a horse and you may get tired also
color blindness and later calling
yourself a friend of a friend but it was
only a half half of a half of the
incredible just be careful
[Laughter]
[Applause]
problem over here it's a problem anyway